well the benefit of me being blood
ass-naked is that I blend in with the
desert landscape a little bit so that's
nice yeah I only got ten shots total so
if I bring one person down I'm gonna be
shocked named for their but that's there
now see I I just think you're telling
lies man
you know I don't want to call you out
here right on livestream but I'm pretty
sure you're lying to me yeah but shots
of the deadly wound no yeah no good okay
well that's that doesn't bode well for
you that doesn't bode well for me but as
long as we stick together we go ass to
ass we should be fine Oh reloading
reloading oh yeah yeah good good good
[Music]
why am I still naked someone said
because I choose to be and because it's
the most natural state of being
the Korean fro will live on in infamy
your defenses boo I'll be on I'll be on
top that's two okay right here oh right
on me yes what I thought oh my god you
scared the piss out of it I can't come
to your [ __ ] well I'm in trouble here
well there's gonna be a problem huh he
startled me so badly
this douche look it's [ __ ] douchey
guy you seeing this guy he's got an
outfit that just makes you want to punch
him right in the face I mean everything
about him just I hate I don't know just
something about it's a channel all my
hate into the one one person standing in
front of you right now if there's
someone that I if I could only kill one
person just he blew a kiss to me oh my
god he's he's pretty much done forever
I'm so glad we're in agreement about
everything here okay I'm down I got
first day nobody touched me I can heal
all wounds and
and painkillers nobody stands a chance
from another first aid kit one more
first aid kit everybody sound the party
over food showed up that's not good hang
on let me I hear the sounds of war throw
my body out of this window here how
could I miss the only other naked man on
this entire island good let me open your
box man thank you that's nice it's it's
good nice wouldn't let you emote at me
no no we're not skipping past this
understand we're talking about what what
button is the omoi de button about the
tilde oh boy dude my favorite singers
coming to town oom Lada everything
that's your that's the name of your fan
base right the ohm latte you're coming
on my stairs oh [ __ ]
you're scary so I've got a um P I've got
a scar
alright brag about your battle wounds
geez I know where's that I got care
[ __ ] first where the [ __ ] you want to
become part of the Ummah lotta gang and
subscribe ring that bell if you want to
be part of the UM la days because we la
days we know how to have fun little
doodle do Oh El Pozo hoes it we're never
gonna be able to make it all the way to
El Pozo fine we'll do we're never gonna
be able to make it all the way to
military mm ah the sweet smell of death
boom I got a trench coat there's no way
I can lose it's this guy right here well
okay if I just hit the stairs it didn't
say my symbol was block this guy in my
house I'm coming out the window in the
back towards you I'm gonna [ __ ] bail
on that [ __ ] don't worry guys I killed
the stairs you're all worried about the
stairs why are your characters
half-naked don't judge no you're not
part of the naked gang no no I you're
not part of the naked gang no no no you
ain't doing nothing doing nothing no
beat the [ __ ] out of you my superiority
my alpha status you you are obviously
better that that's how that worked I'm
pretty sure I'm almost on to present a
positive that's with that that meant
yeah what do I want to hit farm you know
I wanna hit farm
I figured with your your farming
abilities I've been I've been getting
pretty good at farming I'm not gonna lie
I'm not gonna lie this is me when I'm
landing in farm now smash that farm
smash its that farm oh I'm gonna lay
into that farm
oh that farms never gonna know what's
gonna gonna hit that farm and I ain't
gonna call that farm back you know I'm
not Tyler you know I'm not right yeah I
never call far back your corn cob locked
on target
or bush or if I crouch down but be quiet
is what separates the boys from the man
[Laughter]
[Music]